bro Nakamura who had a very very fine
day today you Carla tell us what
happened in the game yeah today's
today's game was certainly interesting
um you know I wasn't I wasn't actually
expecting levanta to try really hard
after what happened yesterday so I was
bit surprised that he that he played in
English but I kind of had some ideas so
I just went for this age five eh forum
thought it would be interesting at least
a game and I think it's hard to judge
which is basically white white pushed
all his pawns forward it's like and it's
very positionally strong perhaps if you
can keep things the way they are a few
pieces can come off but there's always
some counter place certainly and so I
thought it was roughly even in the
middle game I felt like Lewan right
around like move 6117 used too much time
and he didn't play the right
continuation and then then it then he
was just some trouble and I mean I
didn't didn't really let him off the
hook after that exactly a very
impressive game but overall a tournament
that you've got to be very satisfied
with and you've now tied for second and
undefeated Oh your overall thoughts
about the tournament yeah I think plus
three is the right results the more i
think about it but i think probably the
right way the right order is that as I
draw against carwin and I beat a vache
yes sir I think that's probably the
correct order 4 plus 3 but Delta to win
three games and draw 6 is very good
another tournament without a loss so I
mean I can't complain yeah it's going
very well now your thoughts turn to st.
to the sink fell Cup in st. Louis as the
Grand Chester moves on so to speak
you're just thoughts as you start to
imagine what st. Louis is going to bring
um I haven't thought that far our head
I'm just ready to go on vacation I'll
worry about that sometime next month
enjoy your vacation thanks that was
Hikaru Nakamura sharing with his
thoughts on this the first in the grand
chester here in norway he had a
fantastic result